la commission européenne bernard et
pêcheurs dans le golfe de gascogne et
aujourd'hui c'est son dernier jour de
pêche l'année est loin d'être terminée
mais bernard pech la langoustine et la
pêche à la langoustine est limitée par
l'europe
bernard et ses camarades pêcheurs du
golfe de gascogne ont déjà atteint leur
quota sur son bateau de retour au port
ils râlent contre bruxelles où siège la
commission européenne pourtant il y à
certaines décisions qui ne peuvent pas
être prises efficacement par un seul
pays et qu'ils doivent relever plutôt
d'un continent les quotas de pêche en
mer sont l'exemple parfait de cet
impératif
les poissons et les crustacés ne
connaissent pas les frontières ils ne
sont pas très au courant des limites des
eaux territoriales et ne se baladent que
très rarement avec leur passeport
il faut donc une règle pour tous les
pêcheurs des 28 pays mais une décision
de la commission bruxelles est toujours
difficile à comprendre parce qu'on ne
perçoit pas bien qui en est à l'origine
on imagine des fonctionnaires que l'on
n'a pas élu et qui ne sont jamais venus
expliquer leur décision aux abords du
golfe de gascogne
mais en réalité la commission européenne
est composé d'un commissaire par pays
est désigné par les gouvernements
nationaux
c'est vrai que le lien démocratique
entre la population et les commissaires
est un peu distendues
le président de la commission est
désigné par le conseil européen c'est à
dire par tous les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui composent l'union la
commission et son président chapeaute
toute l'administration une trentaine de
milliers de fonctionnaires de l'union
qui se trouve à bruxelles
dans la capitale belge au coeur de
l'europe le rôle de la commission c'est
de faire appliquer tous les traités
toutes les règles qui font que les 28
pays forme d'un grand ensemble
démocratique et économique sans
frontières intérieures
c'est ce que voulaient les pères de
l'europe au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale qui a ravagé le
continent
seulement l'unité c'est très compliqué
parce que tout ce que décide l'union à
bruxelles concernent des sujets qui
étaient traités par les états comme les
quotas de pêche par exemple
la commission fait respecter la libre
circulation des marchandises et des
hommes dans les 28 pays
elle surveille aussi la politique
économique de chaque état surtout ceux
qui ont l'euro comme monnaie
c'est par exemple la règle des 3% de
déficit qu'il ne faut pas dépasser
la commission a aussi une politique
étrangère qui est censé représenter la
voix de l'europe mais on ne l'entend pas
beaucoup parce qu'on arrive rarement à
se mettre d'accord sur une position
claire en revanche dans d'autres
domaines
l'union à une action très concrète elle
distribue des aides pour financer des
routes et d'autres infrastructures et
soutenir les filières comme la filière
agricole malgré sa bruxelles et la
commission européenne sont souvent les
boucs émissaires de bien des européens
il faut dire que les hommes politiques
nationaux ont pris l'habitude
d'expliquer que tout ce qui ne marche
pas et dû à l'europe
la réalité est bien plus complexe et si
par exemple le rock ne limitait pas la
pêche à la langoustine ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il n'y aurait plus de
langoustines dans le golfe de gascogne
et bernard ne serait plus pêcheurs